Hello everyone, in this video I will explain how to set up Anki for your French
learning and how to learn vocabulary with it.
There are no excuses to not listen some French so the rest of the video will be
in French, but of course you have English subtitles in YouTube settings.
Somewhere here maybe?
Donc bonjour tout le monde, aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer comment utiliser
Anki pour apprendre du vocabulaire et pour progresser en français.
Notre niveau dans une langue dépend du nombre de mots qu'on connaît.
Il y a des règles de grammaire, mais le plus important c'est le vocabulaire.
Imaginez vous voulez dire « I eat a banana » en français.
Si vous connaissez le vocabulaire mais que vous ne connaissez pas la grammaire,
ça donne ça.
on comprend
Si vous connaissez la grammaire et la conjugaison mais que vous ne connaissez
pas les mots de vocabulaire, ça donne ça.
on ne comprend pas ce que vous mangez.
Bref, le plus important c'est de connaître des mots de vocabulaire.
La grammaire c'est bien sûr important mais notre niveau va beaucoup dépendre des
mots qu'on connaît.
Et donc maintenant la question c'est comment apprendre le vocabulaire en
français.
Utiliser Anki c'est très efficace pour apprendre du vocabulaire et je vais vous
montrer comment faire.
La vidéo est organisée par chapitre donc n'hésitez pas à aller au chapitre qui
vous intéresse.
Anki c'est un logiciel gratuit qui permet d'apprendre et de réviser des cartes
mémoires grâce à la répétition espacée.
Grâce à un système SRS.
Avec Anki vous allez pouvoir créer vos cartes mémoires et ensuite vous allez
pouvoir les réviser régulièrement.
Une carte mémoire c'est une carte avec un recto et un verso.
Pour apprendre du vocabulaire français vous allez par exemple écrire le mot
français au recto et sa traduction au verso.
Anki c'est efficace parce que ça utilise un système SRS pour spaced repetition
system.
Notre mémoire c'est comme un millefeuille.
On a une mémoire à court terme et on a une mémoire à long terme.
L'objectif quand on apprend du vocabulaire c'est de pousser l'information dans
notre mémoire long terme.
Et pour ça on utilise un système SRS pour spaced repetition system.
Quand on va réviser une carte Anki va nous demander est-ce que tu te souviens de
ce mot ?
Et là on a deux options soit on répond oui soit on répond non.
Si on répond oui on va revoir la carte après trois jours.
Si on répond non on va revoir la carte le lendemain le jour d'après.
Plus on mémorise plus les révisions vont être espacées dans le temps.
Ça permet d'être sûr que l'information descend dans notre mémoire long terme.
Anki permet donc de créer des cartes et de les réviser avec un système SRS.
C'est optimisé pour la mémorisation et donc c'est très utile pour apprendre du
vocabulaire.
Bon ça c'était pour la présentation.
Maintenant je vais vous montrer comment installer Anki.
Le plus simple c'est de l'installer sur votre ordinateur.
Vous allez sur le site d'Anki vous avez le lien dans la description.
Vous cliquez sur télécharger et vous installez le logiciel.
Du coup on se retrouve sur mon écran et je vous montre ça directement.
Télécharger Anki donc là vous avez les différentes versions.
Moi je suis sur Windows.
J'ai téléchargé je lance Anki.
J'installe le logiciel.
Là dans cette fenêtre il me demande est-ce que je veux la dernière version
ou est-ce que je veux choisir ma version.
Je vais appuyer sur entrée pour avoir la dernière version.
Il installe et j'ai accès à Anki.
Donc là je peux sélectionner ma langue pour l'interface d'Anki.
La langue utilisée pour les menus.
Je vais mettre anglais.
Et voilà Anki.
Donc là je vais présenter très rapidement les menus mais en gros vous avez les
decks.
Donc les paquets de cartes.
Je peux par exemple créer un paquet où je vais appeler ça French Vocabulary.
Maintenant j'ai ce paquet de cartes avec le nombre de nouvelles cartes.
Le nombre de cartes apprises et le nombre de cartes à revoir.
Je peux ajouter une carte.
Donc là quand je clique sur Add, il me donne cette carte.
Et par exemple je vais mettre Bonjour et je vais mettre Hello au derrière de la
carte.
Donc le mot en français et au verso.
Le mot sa traduction dans votre langue.
Je peux ajouter et là vous voyez déjà que j'ai une carte.
Alors bon là il m'a ajouté la carte dans le deck défaut.
Et vous pouvez aller dans Browse.
Donc recherchez.
Et ici vous allez avoir toutes les cartes qui ont été créées.
Là il me dit que la carte est dans le deck défaut.
Je peux le changer comme ceci.
Move Cards.
Si je ferme, on voit bien que maintenant j'ai ma carte dans mon deck French
Vocabulary.
Et enfin on a Stat.
Donc là ça va être les statistiques de votre apprentissage.
Je vais revenir dessus mais ça peut être important pour rester motivé.
Et après il y a le bouton "sync" pour synchroniser notamment si vous utilisez Anki
sur votre portable et sur votre ordinateur.
C'est pour être sûr que vous avez toujours les mêmes cartes sur vos différents
supports.
Pour l'application mobile elle est payante sur Apple.
Je crois qu'elle coûte environ 25 euros mais elle est gratuite sur Android.
Pour les personnes qui ont des iPhone, attention à la version que vous achetez.
Car il existe des applications qui s'appellent Anki mais qui ne sont pas les
vraies Anki.
Et donc vous ne pourrez pas accéder aux cartes que vous avez créées sur votre
ordinateur.
Vous ne pourrez pas synchroniser vos cartes entre votre ordinateur et votre
portable.
Donc faites attention à prendre la bonne application.
Je vous conseille de créer des cartes avec des phrases.
Quand vous débutez c'est plus efficace que de créer des cartes avec juste un
mot.
Faire des cartes avec des phrases ça permet d'apprendre le vocabulaire dans un
contexte.
Et en plus vous voyez régulièrement des structures de phrases.
Idealement chaque carte doit avoir un seul mot inconnu.
Si vous créez des cartes avec des phrases difficiles avec beaucoup de mots que
vous ne connaissez pas, ça ne va pas être efficace.
Au début comme vous n'avez pas beaucoup de vocabulaire,
vous pouvez créer une carte avec deux voir maximum trois mots que vous voulez
apprendre, mais il faut vite commencer à créer des cartes avec un seul mot
inconnu.
Il ne faut pas créer trop de cartes trop vite.
On peut avoir envie de demander à ChatGPT 100 phrases pour créer des cartes
rapidement.
Mais ça risque de ne pas être très utile.
En fait, plus vous passez de temps à créer une carte, mieux vous allez
mémoriser.
Vous pouvez essayer de créer une phrase personnelle et pourquoi pas ajouter une
image sur la carte.
On mémorise toujours mieux avec des images.
Par exemple, le midi au déjeuner je mange une pizza.
Vous pouvez ajouter la photo de votre pizza préférée ou la photo d'un restaurant
où vous allez souvent manger le midi pour le déjeuner.
En créant des cartes personnalisées, vous mémorisez plus facilement.
Et du coup, il y a cette dernière question.
Utilisez un deck préconstruit ou faire ses propres cartes.
Vous pouvez télécharger des deck, des paquets de cartes préconstruits sur le
site d'Anki.
C'est pratique si vous n'avez pas beaucoup de temps.
Et en plus, ces decks ont des cartes avec les mots français les plus fréquents.
Les mots qu'on utilise le plus souvent.
C'est efficace parce que bien évidemment, il vaut mieux apprendre les mots les
plus fréquents en premier.
Mais à part ces deux arguments, je pense que c'est toujours mieux de créer ses
propres cartes.
Quand vous créez vos cartes, ce sont vos cartes.
Elles sont personnalisées et elles sont beaucoup plus faciles à mémoriser.
C'est un conseil.
Vous faites ce que vous voulez et vous pouvez bien sûr essayer les deux
solutions.
Et pourquoi pas mélanger les types de cartes.
Je parle souvent des habitudes, mais c'est un concept clé quand on apprend une
langue.
Construire une habitude, c'est le plus important.
Il faut étudier un peu chaque jour.
Avec Anki, vous allez devoir réviser des cartes un peu tous les jours.
Et donc il est important de construire une habitude.
Je vais résumer très rapidement le livre Atomic Habits de James Clear.
Mais en gros, il faut créer l'habitude à partir d'une habitude qui existe déjà.
Par exemple, si tous les matins vous buvez un café, vous pouvez vous dire
maintenant,
tous les matins, quand je bois mon café, je révise mes cartes Anki.
Il faut que l'habitude soit facile et évidente.
J'ai appris le piano pendant trois ans et au début j'habitais dans un petit
appartement parisien.
Je devais ranger mon piano dans un placard et le sortir à chaque fois pour
m'entraîner.
Je ne m'entraînais quasiment jamais.
J'ai déménagé dans un appartement plus grand.
Mon piano était toujours installé au même endroit et je n'avais qu'à appuyer sur
"on" et je pouvais m'entraîner.
Parce que c'était plus évident, je me suis plus entraîné.
C'est vrai pour n'importe quel type d'habitude.
Il faut que ce soit évident et facile.
Il faut que l'habitude soit satisfaisante.
Les statistiques de Anki sont utiles pour ça.
Vous voyez le nombre de cartes qui augmentent
Vous avez la heatmap qui montre les jours où vous avez étudié, etc.
Ces statistiques peuvent rendre l'habitude satisfaisante.
Apprendre cinq nouveaux mots par jour, ça semble facile.
Apprendre 35 nouveaux mots une fois par semaine, ça semble difficile.
Construire une habitude, c'est le meilleur moyen pour apprendre.
Ce n'est pas vraiment le sujet de cette vidéo, donc je ferai sûrement une vidéo
sur les habitudes plus détaillées plus tard.
Le risque avec Anki, c'est d'avoir trop de cartes à réviser.
Le risque, c'est d'être découragé et d'abandonné, d'arrêter son habitude.
Donc, il faut faire attention à ne pas être submergé, à ne pas avoir trop de
cartes.
Pour ça, on utilise le nombre de nouvelles cartes à apprendre par jour.
Je recommande de commencer à cinq et au bout d'une ou deux semaines, vous pouvez
augmenter.
En général, 10 nouvelles cartes par jour, c'est OK.
15, ça commence à demander plus de travail.
Comme les cartes s'accumulent au fur et à mesure, si vous commencez en étant
très motivé et que vous apprenez 20 nouvelles cartes par jour,
vous allez vraiment voir l'impact seulement une ou deux semaines après.
Donc, il faut vraiment faire attention et augmenter progressivement.
Également, si vous ratez une journée de révision, les cartes vont s'accumuler.
Dans ce cas, mettez le nombre de nouvelles cartes à zéro et faites d'abord
toutes vos révisions avant d'apprendre de nouvelles cartes.
Le nombre de nouvelles cartes par jour, c'est la vitesse à laquelle vous allez,
mais il faut faire attention à ne pas vouloir aller trop vite.
Le plus important, c'est l'immersion. C'est écouter la
langue.
Dans votre routine, il ne faut pas passer plus de temps à faire des cartes et à
les réviser qu'à faire de l'immersion. C'est contre-productif.
Bon, au début, créer des cartes, ça va peut-être prendre un peu plus de temps.
Mais si, à un moment, vous voyez que vous passez plus de temps à réviser des
cartes qu'à faire de l'immersion, réduisez votre nombre de nouvelles cartes par
jour.
Également, il faut éviter le pilote automatique. Quand on revoit tous les matins
nos cartes,
bah parfois, on peut passer en pilote automatique, c'est-à-dire juste revoir
sans vraiment être concentré.
Dans ce cas, l'apprentissage devient assez inefficace et donc, il faut faire
attention à être un minimum concentré pour vraiment apprendre le vocabulaire.
Et dernier point, il faut donc faire attention à maîtriser son nombre de cartes.
Si vous manquez de temps, diminuez votre nombre de cartes. Il vaut mieux moins
de cartes et passer plus de temps à réviser en étant concentré, plutôt que de
vouloir augmenter au maximum le nombre de cartes par jour.
Il faut trouver son rythme de croisière et, si besoin, ajuster de temps en
temps.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu. Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à
laisser un "j'aime" et un "commentaire".
J'ai également un Patreon si vous voulez me soutenir. Il y a un Discord privé et
je crée aussi du contenu exclusif.
Donc, si vous voulez me soutenir, n'hésitez pas à cliquer sur le lien dans la
description.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et à la prochaine !